people should be studying the most
successful companies in the world not
individuals don't worry about dave or
gary or tony or grant what are
successful people doing one of the
biggest mistakes i've made in my life
was tracking people that were doing
better than me so what like i made so
many dumb ass decisions because dave did
it or the millionaire next door i don't
want to be the millionaire next door i
want to know what jeff bezos is doing i
want to know what the boys at google are
doing why does a guy like mark
zuckerberg go from college dorm room to
one of the richest people on the planet
that's who we should be studying and
don't listen to everybody because those
people have financial freedom to the
point to where they can do anything they
want you cannot mess up some of these
people's situation they couldn't screw
it up if they wanted to the 10x rule
says hey look you want to scale to a
point to where you have the life you
deserve it's not about the money you
want or the money you need scale your
business so you can walk away from it
and money never stops taking care of you
and your family you don't need to study
27 different worms you study one more
and you're probably going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube we're listening to
so many different people that people do
nothing this is the new crisis of our
era people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting so if you listen to dave
dave says buy a house then you listen to
grant grant says that's stupid you're
not going to do anything and if you're
never going to buy any real estate hey
go ahead and buy one house you're going
to regret it later and you're going to
be like i wish i had done what cardone
said but you got to do something and
what you don't want to do is listen to
god and the devil because then you get
stuck in purgatory and you don't have
any fun at all need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you have
michael jordan level talent at something
so get ready to study success use
negativity as fuel and go harder on
yourself with grant cardone and my take
on his top 10 rules success to give you
the confidence motivation and belief
that you need enjoy
rule number two help others look for
somebody to help man there's people all
over this planet man just lost i told my
mom when i was 16 years old one day one
day i'm gonna be successful one day
one day i'm gonna be successful and one
day i'm gonna help a lot of people
and i said that to her because i wanted
somebody to help me
see i've always loved helping people
always
i am most happy when i'm helping someone
else
nothing to do with money
if i can help somebody
not give them something but if i can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
why don't we do this man
why don't we make it 100 thank you man
and you keep it thank you boss thank you
yeah you see that big smile on his face
when i did that just like
pop helps a buddy rule number three use
negativity as fuel
looks like i'm showing off all the time
here's what you don't know
you don't see all the hard work the
years the years
don't quit okay if i had to quit
i wouldn't have the wife wouldn't have
the kids wouldn't have the bird wouldn't
have the cars wouldn't have the real
estate wouldn't have my middle my my
physical and my mental health i wouldn't
have the success nobody would know me
nobody would know me
so you see where i'm at today but you
don't see all the days that i got up
when i didn't want to get up
all the days when i went to work and
made a call when i didn't want to make a
call all the days that i called somebody
back that had rejected me over and over
and over again all the book publishers
that wouldn't publish my books all the
tv people that said no man you're too
noisy
all that
all the things that are happening to you
right now the sick days the illnesses
the family that's pulling against you
the friends that counted you out uh the
problems you've had in your past
whatever it is look you can use it as an
excuse or you can use it as fuel rule
number four be hard on yourself i just
had a coaching call with some friends of
mine they come in every month and and
they're working on their business
they're going to bust a million dollars
this month when i met them they were
literally the company was not making
money they're going to make a million
dollars they asked me a question today
that i want to talk about they're like
dude how are you
everybody we talk to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the answer you have is
different i said what do you mean well
it seems like you're hard on people
i said no man i'm not being hard on
people
i'm just trying to take care of my
environment
i'm not trying i don't practice being a
a dik
i'm trying
to take care of my environment my
decisions are about my environment right
so little grant
little grants this this little phone
right here this is little grand he got
issues he needs to clean up his issues
grant's got to get hard on grand
okay you guys out there y'all y'all so
soft on your people it's cause you're
soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money
you end up with people betraying you you
end up with people taking advantage of
you even your kids don't appreciate you
do you got to be hard on yourself i'm
hard on everybody around me but mostly
i'm hard on me
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five become the person
you should be the theme that runs in my
life is just disappointment throughout
the whole thing particularly the first
from fifth to from 10 years old to 25
and then 25 to 50
you know
yeah i was doing better because i i had
a drug problem at 16. oh you did yeah
was that the disappointment or was it
like no no no the drugs were just the
drugs were a byproduct you know it was
the disappointment was
you know
the school thing
school was disappointing no uncles no
dad right no i didn't know direction
just boredom
that's why what you do with these
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure i didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of us no
no no when my dad died i kept waiting
for one of the uncles to step up and
they didn't got it and that pissed me
off because i'm like dude somebody's got
to step up and give me a little guidance
here but you but you had older um
brothers my older brother died when i
was 20. right so 10 years after my dad
died
so there was no men
just a bunch of women and mom mom wasn't
like setting big goals for you no no my
mom my mom my mom grew up in bread lunch
so
you know i'd go to my mom i remember i
did a deal when i was 30.
bought my first piece of real estate
and um mom i bought this piece of real
estate it was three million dollars a
1.9 million dollars and she's like wow
that's great but you know i just i love
you just the way you are
right and i hung up the phone she said
that to me a thousand times
and i hope the phone said yeah but i
don't love me the way i am
and then my counselor buddy dale says
you need to love yourself the way you
are i said he never going to have it
dude
right i said that's the big lot
i don't want to love me the way i want
to become the guy i should be rule
number six stack up some experience
nobody ever taught me when i was going
to school 17 years of school nobody ever
said hey maybe you want to stack up some
experiences
and then what happens is kids rather
than going to college what they do today
is they'll go travel for
for a year
what you got to flip it
go get your work ethic in
bank some money
make some money i'm gonna do this
left-handed
make some money and then go on the trip
of your life
oh
left-handed i'm so good i'm so good at
everything
you got to have confidence man so look
look look and by the confidence comes
from doing stuff because it comes from
doing business
not from traveling right like i know
people that traveled when they were
young and then they go back into the
workplace in the business place and
they're like dude i don't have any
confidence in business
you want to have confidence in business
confidence and money confidence with
your family confidence that you can go
places and look money might not make you
happy i know some of you believe that
but
it gives you the security to go where
you want to do what you want and stay as
long as you want if you can get that
money right rule number seven be fair to
yourself yesterday i had to make a phone
call to a guy hey bro you're not getting
the deal
let me tell you what the deal is it's a
115 million dollar loan
okay and there's two groups doing the
deal
they're gonna hate seeing this when they
see it one group is at point four zero
one group is point twenty five zero this
is my friend right here my friends too
much money man and this guy this other
guy over here got me more proceeds he
gave me more assurances
i had to tell my friends sorry bruh
sorry
i gotta go with my boy down here
oh man grant we've been friends we've
been friends you like me i like you
we've been to dinner you know my family
sorry bro
i don't know what to tell you dude
it would not be fair to my family to my
children to my investments to my money
to my hard work to this deal to my
investors it would not be fair by the
way if there were no investors it would
not be fair to me
to pay more money to do business with
you because you're my friend sorry i
don't know what to tell you
this is where you guys all get confused
he's my friend if he's my friend
then i should not have to pay for that
relationship
by the way if he's my friend he will be
my friend after i make this hard
decision rule number eight have a dream
i remember hearing a story my twin
brother told me years ago about this
dude i think his name was vincent
wealthy wealthy dude in london
everywhere he went
he went on a choppa what a way to ride
on
okay i knew i was not in a place that
ever knew that
but i always thought every once in a
while i'd be like dude what would it
take
you know what i did i quit on the dream
before i even had the dream i'm like
i'll never have that quit on the dream
before i had the dream
i've done this my whole life don't make
this mistake
don't quit on the dream before you have
the dream okay and when i heard that
vincent was flying around on a
helicopter all the time i quit on my
dream before i even had it i just
assumed i could never do that i'll never
have that and then one day i went back
and started looking at dude what do i
have to do to go back and make my dreams
a reality
and even if they don't become a reality
at least have the dream rule number nine
be prepared i was in a deal
i was in a deal and
i sold the deal i made four million
dollars on the deal i already knew and i
made the mistake of judging based on the
profit rather than the opportunity okay
the guy that bought the deal from me
ended up selling it for
um
13 million more
so you would have made 17. i made 17
million rather than 4 million okay so
now why do i tell you that because i did
not know when i was a young salesman at
25 26 27 years old any more than jared
yeah when he started working here or
when he had a job at that that corporate
company cut your bonus yeah they jacked
you um he did not know then he would be
negotiating 100 million dollar contracts
at a company i did not know when i was
selling automobiles in 25 26 years old
that i was preparing
for
100 million dollar deals when i would be
55 years old yeah like you you guys
don't like you got to be more positive
about where your show ends up right you
got to train today like i'm going to be
in a big deal tomorrow
right because it's going to happen if
you just stay focused on it so for those
of you jared made a good point about the
sales thing you don't think you're a
salesperson because you're you're
running a dental business yeah your top
line is your revenue line that's called
sales dude have you got a problem guys
if you if you get a lot so much
distraction right okay so let me know
right if you if you buy a car and you
pay too much like like you could every
time you could deal poorly and you could
pay too much money and interest you
could pay too much money for the car
that could cost you
five to ten grand you could buy a house
and negotiate a bad loan you could buy
at the wrong time you could negotiate a
bad deal that could cost dude in 2008
people lost hundreds of thousands of
dollars and people made millions and
hundreds of millions watching the
opportunity so it you can't see
opportunities you're not ready for okay
you cannot catch a wave
you're not prepared to surf
it is impossible and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have a dream look at this i
thought it was chilly
no it felt so good wow that breeze is
nice
come on boys
you know the story though
the young bull
and the old bull at the top of the top
of the hill right no one got that joke
earlier yeah well you know the story
right the young bull says to the whole
bullet system
there you go
oh man my way home while we go down
there and
breed a bull
breed one that cattle bring something in
cows
and an old bull says hey why don't we
just go down there and breed them all
that's a 10x bull right there
from 15 to 25 i was using drugs every
day
so when i tell you
hey you can do anything
i was a habitual
daily drug user
overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay i was i don't know if i was trying
to kill myself at the time or i was just
didn't know what i was doing or stupid
or whatever like
i was a walking time bomb
and i was not to be trusted by my family
by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25 that i could have a positive
influence on
i was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people i went to
school with and the places i worked at i
lost seven jobs in a row i was
unemployable
25 i went to a treatment center and said
i got to turn this around
i got to turn this around i cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me i make
poor decisions when i'm using them
i i i go out with the wrong people hang
with the wrong people end up in the
wrong fights i literally got like when
you're using drugs you're going to pick
fights you can't win not in a lifetime
you're going to get in the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases
and you're going to miss a lot of great
opportunities
so first thing is
you can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions and when you're
under the influence
and i don't want to preach to you i'm
just telling you what what advice i'd
give myself if i was on the comeback and
i was
15 years old and being influenced by
everybody smoking the kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you
did and just making poor decisions so i
tell you hey you got you got to figure
out how how is that going to somehow
advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if i'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can i pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again i don't mean to sound like a
like a
a preacher or anything because i'm
definitely not that we're going to have
a great time this weekend
i'm here for a week we're going to have
a lot of fun but i couldn't do that if i
was still under the influence every day
people should be studying the most
successful companies in the world not
not individuals
don't worry about dave or gary or tony
or grant
what are successful people doing
you know i one of the biggest mistakes
i've made in my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
so what
like like like i made so many dumb ass
decisions because uh
dave did it
or the millionaire next door
that book
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door i want to know what jeff bezos is
doing i want to know what the boys at
google are doing okay why why does a guy
like mark zuckerberg go from
college dorm room to one of the richest
people on the planet
that's who we should be studying
and and don't listen to everybody else
because those people have financial
freedom to the point to where they they
can do anything they want
like you cannot mess up some of these
people's situation
they couldn't screw it up if they wanted
to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need
scale your business so you can walk away
from it and money never stops taking
care of you and your family you don't
need to study 27 different words
you study one more and you're probably
going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube we're listening to
so many different people
that that people do nothing
this this is the new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to dave dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid you're not going to
do anything
and if you're never going to buy any
real estate hey go ahead and buy one
house yeah you're going to regret it
later and you're going to be like i wish
i had done what cardone said but but you
got to do something and what you don't
want to do is listen
to god and the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all all
commitments require investments in time
and money all commitments
you cannot make a commitment without
time and money being invested
time and money has to be invested you
have to invest time and money
if it's not on your schedule you're not
committed if you don't have money back
by that time on your calendar if it's
not costing you money or you don't have
money deposited right there you are not
committed
where you have your money is where your
personal spiritual emotional physical
commitments go wherever your money is is
who you are most committed to
wells fargo bank of america citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
wells fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising in the market
because you guys are committed to the
lie
the big marketing scam of the universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not bore
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too
will be able to stay at a holiday inn
for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there
and eat all you want for as long as you
want by the way
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the
belt that you bought and put on your
credit card
that you can't write off by the way so
this is what americans are doing people
all around the world spend 40 hours a
week running around hustling
yeah they get hundred dollars what do
they do now they run over here to the
bank drop off the hundred bucks then
they run back out and do another 40
weeks pick up a thousand dollars man had
a great week didn't i bang and then they
run over here and drop it off to the
bank these are the good americans
the bad americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it
the good americans
run
run around collecting a thousand dollars
five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars hustlers hustlers man hard
workers they they get sophisticated
uh i'm gonna put a little money in the
bank over here over here at wells fargo
i'm gonna have a little over here at
citibank i'm gonna spread this
around
i want to be a slave to many
not a slave to a few
i'm gonna give a little to the bank of
america i'm gonna give a little bit of
citibank i'm gonna give a little bit to
the wells fargo i'm gonna give a little
bit to fidelity and merrill lynch i'm
gonna give a little bit to my ira and my
401k i'm gonna bust my ass i'm gonna
spend 40 years killing myself to make
sure all these institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
[Music]
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey mr cardone
we got another dummy
[Music]
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours
put together a little bank extremely
disciplined dumbass
and and he
saved hundred thousand dollars with us
and we'd like to know mr cardone
if you would like to borrow that money
his money
yeah i sure would because we know mr
cardone that you'll put that money to
work
okay
this guy that gave it to us all he wants
to do is work
i'm like yeah send me that money bro
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
gonna call nine other people
they're going to take his 100 grand and
they're going to say they're going to
they're going to lend it out
900 000
of it and this is the banking system
and that is debt by the way
that u.s dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you
this isn't a magic act these are basic
skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most sales people have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching
manipulation
tactics
dodge the question
don't answer control the customer
uh the the whole newer linguistics bull
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro-linguistic
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the lnlp stuff i'm
just telling you we've hired
hundreds and hundreds of salespeople
i've been with tens of thousands of
salespeople i have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bull
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
i don't want drama dude i want
production
so
so when when he sits a certain way i
don't start thinking about man um
imagine being in a sales sales
presentation i'm like i got to be like
him and then now i got to be like her
and now i got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that
you
you man what a diss
i want to be me
the power resonates for me my truth my
authenticity and my transparency
okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it i never ask him to be
me i'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say
well i'm with you
everybody try that
no no i didn't say it like that i said
i'm with you
see and i'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high i knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay so you see i i'm he he gets to be
him
but the words will work because all i'm
doing is basically agreeing with the
customer this isn't a trick here
okay uh this course is uh i'm doing a
dinner tonight for twenty five thousand
dollars at my house okay i think we got
two slots left
the entire 25 000 goes to the grant
cardone foundation any of you want to
put 25 grand in please see one of my
people come have dinner at my house
we'll spend a couple hours over there
the money's gonna go to help kids some
of you in a room immediately say
oh my god 25 grand that's a lot of money
man i know that
you don't think i know 25 000 is a lot
of money i'm the one that decided what
the freaking entry would be
i said what would be too much 25 grand
25 grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like that damn that's
a lot of money okay and the people that
it's a lot of money that think small
that go small and don't want to help
won't come to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude i'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
grand get pictures with him at his new
home
with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and i get
to write it off i get to bang the irs
who hates the irs
well this is this is a chance to give
them a good
okay so you see what i'm doing i'm
handling all the objections right now i
understand 25 grand a lot of money man i
know what you got to do to earn 25 grand
you got to do crazy stuff to earn 25
grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in a room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour
my wealth ultimately it's not the money
i have it's the knowledge i have
and the belief i have in myself the same
thing for you
but i want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it
you know in the physical universe you
can explain to me what a bougainvillea
is you can explain to me what a beach is
you can explain to me what
uh the gym looks like on the second
floor in cabo san lucas at this
beautiful hotel we're at but
until i visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales
to the sunshine to the mountains until i
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
i was uh i was doing a call today with
percy miller uh master p
and he's like first thing you gotta do
is see it in your mind he grew up in
extreme poverty in the projects and he
says grant first thing i had to do was i
had to see it
in my mind that i could get out second
thing i had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical universe
that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip
you can see the possibility of elon
going to mars you know and and all of a
sudden all those things expand
possibilities so number one you got to
see it in your mind too you got to see
it in the physical universe and this
also includes other people examples of
other people that are doing great things
i'm not just talking about physical
manifestation i'm not talking about
stuff
i'm not talking about watches and
bracelets and rings and houses and cars
i'm talking about how can you actually
manifest something in the real world
that you have in your mind how do you
turn an idea
into reality
and uh these things that i'm sharing
with you will make i'll make it a
possibility uh when you dig deep on them
though it's like okay well how do i get
closer to people that are doing those
things because the third thing is you
got to get closer to the thing you want
if you want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem on planet earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company
an airport and actually fuel them clean
them wash them maybe you got to be a
flight attendant on them put your feet
next to them maybe you have to become a
pilot you're going to have to pay the
price though there's no free lunch here
for anybody including my children
there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at it on the internet
the moment you can get in it it'll be
become even more real to you the fourth
thing is you got to put your feet in
this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there i
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse
you you got to touch the horse and the
fourth thing i'm sorry you got to touch
the hearts and the fourth thing is you
guys got to collaborate with other
people man you got to get in the room
with other people whether you're serving
water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um
offer to serve them to sit down okay
there's a story in my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse
on the internet in a magazine a picture
of it third get closer to it put your
feet on it on the plane on the horse on
the beach in the hotel if i got to go
work there to do it and the fourth thing
is
you got to network with people that have
stuff
okay
again uh i spent some time this week
with
dame dash she's like look you got to get
close to the action you got to get with
the people that are making the moves you
cannot make the moves from your own
neighborhood uh percy miller told me you
cannot make the moves from the projects
you got to move from the projects not
make the moves in the project quit
working street corners
quit selling just a product and start
hanging out with people that have scaled
their think
their ideas
into a reality i'm 19 years old and i
run a consulting firm and uh right now i
just tell you real estate stuff and i
have only about 60 grand from what i've
done saved up yeah and do you think i
need to still wait until 100 grand to
invest in real estate
how long you had 60 grand uh for just
like 12 months now yeah dude like you
got to get the other 40 bro
it's an arbitrary number i just made up
the number it could be 110 it could be
dude it's just it's just so you know
first of all when you get to 100 to call
me
and i'ma probably tell you hey man you
need to wait till you got 350.
but at least then you're gonna be like
you know what i i learned how to make i
learned how to not just make a hundred
save a hundred and put a hundred away
people are investing too soon you guys
are investing three grand here two grand
over here a thousand bucks 500 you're
walking away from it it's never worth
any money it's dumb
and you never create the discipline what
you end up with is a bunch of losses a
bunch of little losses
rather than knowing i have the
confidence that i can make money set it
aside protect it
right protect it like a kid
right
it's not going to get in a wreck i don't
lose it
i would do that first
so was there an age i didn't invest my
my first investment was five thousand
dollars and i blew it
and i'm like i'm not doing that again my
next investment is going to be big
where i'm gonna watch it
because if it's big enough dude if your
life depends on it you'll get up in the
mornings and you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 grand it took
three years to do it all i did was save
money save money save money i put 350
grand in the deal sold that deal for
four million dollars a four million
dollar profit but every last penny you
had i had i had one third of all my
money in that deal i had a million
dollars like a million one
put 350 in my first deal 30 days later
put 450 in a second deal 90 days later
put all the rest of my capital 100 of
all my money
plus 90 grand
in three real estate deals
those are the first three investments i
ever made my the first three or four
investments i made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one
didn't
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
what's it gonna do
it's not going to do anything
it's like going into a casino and you've
got 15
right you get blackjack
so what it's still 15
the first thing you're going to say is
dude i should have bet everything
but you didn't
shouldn't even be in there pay the price
today okay learn to discipline yourself
if you got to go to the gym every day if
you hate going to the gym go to the gym
i don't like going to the gym but i'm
like i don't like my body hurting either
sooner or later if you don't go to the
gym and work your body your body will
it will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms shoulders knees
you name it
it's always going to hurt and as long as
it's hurting how can you be fully
available for the people around you if
your body's certain two you got to eat
good foods okay gotta make decisions i
ain't gonna eat junk
i'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because i'm saying no to junk
and if you can start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
sabrina say hi sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence i'm paying the price when i
do that when i get up before the sun
gets up i'm paying the price when i go
to bed at nine o'clock and i'm not
watching tv and movies and just being
entertained and effective whatever's
coming my way i'm paying the price
when i don't waste the weekends the
weekends make you weak listen to me
weekends are for a week people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay saturday and sunday staying up all
night weak people people are made weak
on the weekends
pay the price okay give up the weekends
for the next
five years and watch what happens
five years man that's a lot of weekends
that's what is that 250 weekends is that
right yeah 250 weekends that means i'm
ahead of the people around me
i'm paying the price today
in hopes that i could pay any price in
the future i'm making 2.4 million
dollars a year
if i could figure out how to get another
200 that's called value add v8 value ad
if i could figure out how to raise a
rent 200 bucks
531
units see that's why the number of units
are so apart
531
[Music]
106 000
times what
is what one point
[Music]
see that creates another 1 million
274 000 of income a year
i'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
bam
that traffic jam
okay i got more cash flow
i just got i don't have to go work i
don't have to beat stuff up
i don't have to go uber you guys are
i'm going to go uber to what what you go
uber to
you end up with seven dollars
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
freedom
i don't want money this money i've had
this money here the whole time okay
it ain't gonna do anything
how many got money in the bank right now
it's useless
[Music]
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money
and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes out
you have to have multiple exits on the
way out
how do i get out of this deal
i know people that have bought real
estate that they're like at cash flows
but they're like i cannot i can never
get rid of this piece of property it's
always going to be a problem for me hang
me around my neck
[Music]
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it i promise you you
will not lose money in this space
warren buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when i read that i'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do i invest in
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like i don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper
when you go buy twenty dollars with a
google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paper bag
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay i want something i can see would
you agree
okay i would rather have that that money
i'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars i'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and i'm gonna buy a flip
charger
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if i use it
everybody agree okay so i want you to
write this down quit saving money
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the the wall
street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
ill-liquid and you do not want to save
money look buying a jet was something i
never dreamed i'd do i never okay i only
started thinking about it four or five
years ago when i'm young and broke and
growing up in louisiana middle class
being told be grateful you got to bite
on a bike be grateful you got clothes on
your back and you get three meals be
grateful for all that you got cause you
got it better than i do i never dreamed
of having my own damn checks
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot you do it you borrow
money okay use money if it requires
money so be it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results you know the secret to
sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything that drains you or causes
you doubt money power fame success all
all of them follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power fame and success even
time off they require attention they're
like jealous lovers they need constant
attention or they're going to leave you
how you invest your time is more
important than how you invest your money
being obsessed with your sense of
purpose across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire i think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area of life because they quit on
all the other ones if you quit on all
the other ones how are you going to get
this one to run nothing inspires me more
than surrounding myself with people who
have achieved more than i have and then
meeting new people i need the obsessed
must surround themselves with people you
trust and respect who think big who've
done bigger than you and who can help
you get to where you want to go you
think you can run only so fast
time is no longer an excuse because the
obsessed
make time they don't make excuses you
have to prepare for inflation hitting
you
and
look i just want to give you a heads up
on this thing it's happening right now i
believe we're already in a recession not
to be a doomsday guy because i think
that there's ways for you to take
advantage of this but i just passed one
two three four five six shops and
nobody's in them
so the american consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand
not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing
uh the mass media to actually distribute
the bad news and we're not talking about
ukraine and cobid we're not talking
about abortion
rulings because all that is just
distraction for the bigger problem which
is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the fed pushing interest rates
uh half a point yesterday
uh there was a rebound in the stock
market this morning i wake up the stock
market rolls over by a thousand points
okay there's going to be blood in the
market so i'm going to do a training on
this i'm going to give you a few tips
right now but first thing is you got to
wake up you got to wake up to what's
happening you got to know that hey
what do i do now what do i do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you got to expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do
you've heard of wealthy people doing
this before how they take advantage of
situations okay i'm going to show you
how to do that whether you have cash or
no you don't have cash whether you have
credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in america
many of you are going out trying to
start a new business where what you
ought to do is just kind of slide
sideways and go buy one the neighbor
next door to you i mean from laundry
mats to plumbers to internet businesses
to coaching businesses you name it
chiropractors dentists like in every
sector that you're involved in right now
in your business or your interest or
your passion i'll promise you
there are
thousands
thousands not one or two but thousands
of small businesses like yours
that are similar to your passion that
would feed your passion that already
have branding already have marketing
built in already have a name already
have a location already have revenue
already have credit lines that you can
literally just slide into
okay but you're not gonna do that you're
not going to do that if all you're doing
is buying into bad news
so number one you can't buy into the bad
news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
is beat out by the need to survive and
the economy to go on the economy will
always go on
okay not just here in america but around
the world always always always we always
get on the other side of bad news so the
first thing you do is you got to keep
your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive
people always like oh yeah i can stay
positive on my own probably not because
you're not going to be on your own
you're going to be surrounded by bad
news everywhere so number two you got to
think about how do you expand despite
the fact that you don't have money and
you don't have credit or you do have
money and you do have credit but you
don't want to use either one because
you're terrified and you will be
the third thing you have to figure out
to do okay is exactly what sectors will
survive
long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction
what happens is weak businesses get
squeezed out weak names get squeezed out
okay a weak operators get squeezed out
and the strong come in and take over
that either the technology takes over
and disrupts a space or a person
typically a person or an operator comes
in and then scales that business how
many rooms are broke right now you're
broke you're like just dead broke
like like if i went and banged on your
credit card it would scream and call the
police
now uh alert
them out right now 911
cannot be used again
that's fine dude that's fine you still
need to have your dreams
you need to start dreaming now how old
are you dude
22 years old you got any money at all
but he's got a little he's got a little
diamond in his ear right here he ain't
got any money but he's like
i'm shining
i'm shining
huh i'm trying to come here come here
man yeah come here man come here
ah
i got a little cubic
[Applause]
come on up here man 22 years old man 22
years old you know what i was doing
every day 22 years old how what do you
weigh man how much you weigh oh you got
one in both ears look at this
get a close-up can you get a close-up
look at that man
oh he's so cool he's so cool look he
looks good too man looks good okay look
how much money do you have to your name
probably like a thousand thousand bucks
what
i feel like a million bucks though yeah
yeah
either way bro you're broke
you agree with that oh yeah you broke
you guys need to admit it you need to
own you need to know when you're broke
the man's got a thousand dollars
right he goes to jail today
he's broke
so so like but but that does not that
does not mean you can't dream
so right now what he's going to do is
his dreams are going to be like okay man
like i just want to i just want to get a
a two grand
or i just want to get some of these
or i want to get a watch
but that's not the dream folks
you know when you were a kid when you're
a kid 12 years old what do you want you
want a car i can't wait till i get a car
you don't think about i'm gonna own a
car dealership
you think i want a car you don't think
hey man i'm gonna make a new car that
flies
right see that's why he ended up with
these little cubics
because his dreams aren't big enough get
off the stage
okay but he's in the right place
he's in the right place everybody agree
the theme that runs in my life is just
disappointment throughout the whole
thing particularly the first from fifth
to from 10 years old to 25
and then 25 to 50
you know
yeah i was doing better because i i had
a drug problem at 16. oh you did yeah
was that the disappointment or was it
like no no no the drugs were just the
drugs were a byproduct you know it was
the disappointment was uh you know
the the school thing
school was disappointing no uncles no
dad right no i didn't know direction
just boredom
that's why what you do with these
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure i didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of us no
no no when my dad died i kept waiting
for one of the uncles to step up and
they didn't
and that pissed me off because i'm like
dude somebody's got to step up and give
me a little guidance here but you but
you had older um brothers my older
brother died when i was 20. right so 10
years after my dad died
so there was no men
just a bunch of women and mom mom wasn't
like setting big goals for you no no my
mom my mom my mom grew up in bread lunch
so
you know i'd go to my mom i remember i
did a deal when i was 30.
bought my first piece of real estate and
um
mom i bought this piece of real estate
it was three million dollars a 1.9
million dollars and she's like wow
that's great but you know i just i love
you just the way you are
right and i hung up the phone she said
that to me a thousand times
and i hung the phone said yeah but i
don't love me the way i am
and then my counselor buddy dale says
you need to love yourself the way you
are i said ain't never gonna happen dude
right i said that's the big lot
i don't want to love me the way i want
to become the guy i should be
i'm 63 years old you know i'll be 64 in
march and
you know i feel like i'm like 14 years
old man i'm like let's roll like let's
go i'm ready to run through walls and
you know fly and learn new stuff i'm
studying uh kryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do i make a play and do i make a play
and what is all this
so you one number one you have to stay
curious
number one curious you have to be
curious when clubhouse came around
clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of the people in
my office including jared was like man
ain't nothing there's nothing there
you know i'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what i
discovered because i was curious about
clubhouse is not because i was curious
about social media i was curious about
people
to me i get energy from people
and so uh
i've been in rooms where
uh alan have y'all met alan yet
so alan allen saw me go in the room one
night and he texted me he's like what
the hell you doing in this room man
and i said what's up he's like get out
of this room
and i said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
i said bro where how am i going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks
just because it has nothing to do with
you doesn't mean your market's not there
and for me to be able to market to a
market
means i need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on on social media the
feedback
i'm not looking for likes and comments
i'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential an idea like all my ideas come
from i don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
i don't i don't create anything i just
grab something that's already there
and i grab it out of something i hear
so the supreme court today announced
they kicked out the mandate uh for the
vaccine i'm like hey man
[Applause]
okay good you like it or don't like it
y'all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh i don't want to
be political say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam
and everybody knows that they're like
i'm throwing in they ain't throwing in
for their side they're throwing in to
keep the other side that they're worried
about
the point of the story is there's energy
there
there's tremendous amounts of energy
that you want to you want to tap into if
you could walk the line and play both of
them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today i'm like
good job man like i got to take a stand
on that now will i lose some people 100
percent
i don't care who i lose there's 8
billion people on this planet
i'm worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it
that's the only way to protect your
brand so have 12 employees i'm sure at
one point you had you know four or five
employees how did you go from four or
five to whatever you have
i had i had two employees
from the age of
29
no no from the age of 30 to
38 years old i had two employees
for eight years
i did everything i was a secretary phone
answer
i did payroll stole for myself
did my taxes i did my own taxes i
wouldn't pay anybody anything
okay from
uh 32 to 38 38 to 45 i added like two or
three people
[Music]
i was i was officing
out of the guest house
at my my my place that i lived at in in
los angeles
it's a big guest house
it was a dude it was an awesome hour
lionel richie lived in that house
you know
it was a cool house right
but it was small thinking man i was
still thinking little
and if you're going to stay small you're
going to get crushed
so i'll push you over the edge 2009 2008
and 2009. so what eventually made you
say you know what i'm just going to make
it
what happened was a guy told me years
before that that bigger's not better and
i believed it
because he busted out
he busted out when he went big and he
says grant bigger's not better man stay
small
and i and i believed that dude and i
carried it on a long time it's bad
advice knowledge is power
bad knowledge is too
so what i did was i stayed small until i
was 45 years old
five employees
i was one of them
so four
and um
when 2008 came i'm like this is stupid
dude like i got a scale
and and that was what 12 uh how many
years ago was that nine years
seven or eight years ago there was no
jet
there was no big office
it just shows you man when you change
your mind when you change your mind and
start like hey i'ma scale this thing out
i'm going to go global i'm going to have
people know me i'm going to get
attention i'm going to get my products
out i'm going to lower my prices i'm
going to bring this thing to market i'm
going to get big bring in good people we
have how many employees we have now
charity
72 at the office we got our partners
here tonight we got an another 150 in uh
in in the real estate game
we're going to expand that we'll
probably pick up another 12 or 15 this
month because the two more deals we're
bringing on
and next year i'm talking about going
global so all everything that happened
everything has happened really good to
us it's happened because of the
expansion
and i just thought we'd take a shot at
one of these obnoxious
[Music]
car videos because i know you guys love
automobiles probably more than i love
them as the private jet flies over us
this is a completely obnoxious just i'm
just gonna be completely transparent for
all the haters and the naysayers and the
[ __ ]
all of you out there that hate on people
that are successful i thought i'd give
you something to hate on today because
content is king right
[Music]
okay today we have my driver car my
driver card is what i roll in this is
the 2021 cullinan rolls royce cullinan
454 thousand dollars of nothing but
super
swag obnoxious thank you bernie marino
the next senator of ohio by the way for
this complete obnoxious beast of an
automobile okay this is not dog friendly
by the way you put a dog back here boom
that bad boy gonna be dead okay now to
my tuesday car to my tuesday car spite
of 458
458 what is it
488 i ain't got my numbers right but i
got my money right okay 488 low rider
tuesday get me ready for hump day okay
this thing is so fast it is freaking
unbelievable brings me to my wednesday
car you know what they say about
wednesdays this hump day okay this is
man this thing is nothing but just
freaking stupid luxury
stupid bentley luxury
368 thousand dollars of nothing but
obnoxious
to bring me to my washer car okay 180
000 mercedes v8 beautiful four-door
sedan when those bad boys are getting
washed i take a day off and drive in the
little bends
just to keep me grateful about the build
much this crazy stuff i got up there
okay that brings me to my friday car
right do i have a friday car yeah this
is my thirsty car this is my friday
rider
this is when i go dj khaled
we the best
this is a phantom folks this is 650 000
and nothing but beast
obnoxious
freaking crazy black on black badge
but let me show you what i use on the
weekends
this is the vehicle
that does it all for me
okay what's up man
my taco truck saturday sundays is my
taco truck this is how i paid for all
the obnoxious
selling on the weekends weekends are for
the week
taco trucks are for the terrific go get
you a damn taco truck so you can buy all
this obnoxious
bentley bling
italiano flatello
familia
cullinan cuisine
grant cardone is the king and i'm
obnoxiously
like my video
you need to dream big i mean you cannot
dream big enough
i'm telling you you can't dream big
enough
you can do more than you're doing
but you can't do more than you're doing
if you hang around with little thinkers
that could be your family members could
be your friends could be people you're
going to school with and hanging out
with look there's a time and a place to
hang out with those people
can't pick your family i mean they say
you can't i wonder sometimes we don't
actually do the picking
and just show up there
without saying that for another
conversation
but i do know once
once you get with your family the family
that you picked or they picked or
however that might work the selection
process
wherever you went to school or go to
school or where you grew up or how you
grew up or religion you grew up in or
whether you're white or black or brown
male or female the question's always
going to be
what can you do
to do more with your life
to find your mission to find your
purpose
to find what you're great at to get
great at the things maybe that you're
not great at that you don't even like
doing think big
telling you can do more and you will do
more than
than you ever imagined if you're ever
successful in your life if you ever hit
it
and you can
you will look back 10 15 20 years from
now say god what was i thinking
what was i thinking i promise you
you know it's like 80 pounds of weight
looks like a lot
when you're 5 or six years old
later it's pretty easy to pick that up
no matter what your frame is as long as
you do the work as long as you do the
work and show up in the gym one day
you'll be able to pick that barbell up
just like in life okay the things that
you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today the things
that you aren't good at the things that
you think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry
are all opportunities for you you failed
the business no problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the visa
mastercard the american express
the training contract you you you did
with us lives on for your next company
you guys understand that
100 of those people
will continue on in some other business
a few of them will commit suicide okay
i'm done
but the rest of them are gonna be like i
gotta go do something and they are going
to restructure and start another company
donald trump has restructured casinos
man this is not a new thing like the big
boys restructure okay
fail boom we restructure we'll create
something new i still got a business
okay you got to get this guy to see this
might fail but you won't because you
won't quit and you're going to be over
here your bank money right now is
earning
.0025 percent
my real estate's earned 20
if you have no place to go you see when
i was 26 years old i was broke 27 i was
broke 28 i was broke 29 i was broke 30 i
was broke you know why because i take
the five grand and i push it off to the
side and i was broke again hustling to
get another five grand why because i
knew where i was going i was going here
i'm like i'm gonna be a millionaire dude
ain't nobody gonna take this deal from
me and i am not gonna wait till i'm 90
years old to get the million bucks
right by the time i'm 33 years old i had
1 million 125
127 bucks in a damn account 1 million
125 127 33 years old and i started with
no money at 25. how
i got the 5 000. i don't need to go buy
something yet i got to add that every
year now i need to learn how to get that
money to grow
20 a year it'll take me 20 years
to get it done how did i get it done in
eight years
[Music]
i must have either added money
or earn more than 20
and it was a combination of both how do
you do that
you don't do it at your job
you can't go you can't be a waitress
making you know 40 000 bucks a year and
all of a sudden make 20 more it's your
job you can't like it just doesn't you
can't just all of a sudden say i'm 20
better give me 20 more money and even if
you could you'll do it one time not
every year
francisco it cannot be such a good
cameraman that he's like hey dude look
give me a 20 raise this year all right
can he do it again next year sooner or
later i'm gonna be like
tapping out dawg okay your photos aren't
that good
i mean they were good
but now they're getting expensive i just
had a coaching call with some friends of
mine they come in every month and and
they're working on their business
they're going to bust a million dollars
this month when i met them they were
literally the company was not making
money they're going to make a million
dollars they asked me a question today
that i want to talk about they're like
dude how are you
everybody we talk to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the the answer you have is
different i said what do you mean well
it seems like you're hard on people
i said no man i'm not being hard on
people
i'm just trying to take care of my
environment
i'm not trying i don't practice being a
a dik
i'm trying
to take care of my environment my
decisions are about my environment right
so little grant
little grants this this little phone
right here this is little grant he got
issues he needs to clean up his issues
grant's got to get hard on grant
okay you you guys out there y'all so
soft on your people is because you're
soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money you end up with people betraying
you you end up with people taking
advantage of you even your kids don't
appreciate you do you got to be hard on
yourself i'm hard on everybody around me
but mostly i'm hard on me five grand is
a doable deal how do i do it it's four
hundred and twelve dollars a month
okay i gotta go steal the money i can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and i wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add five thousand to that
and earn twenty percent it'd be worth a
million one twenty five if you can do
this at 10 it'll be worth 320. some of
you small thinkers out there be like
dude i'll take the 320. how do i get 10
and how do i get 20. you guys have
figured this out you're like
if the play is big enough dude i'll
figure that out everybody agree see see
what i just i shifted your mind by
giving you a target
i don't go to target i get targets and i
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is i want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
i got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20
a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy gc
got rich
i didn't get rich speaking i didn't get
rich selling books
i got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all i did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when i was not watch this
even when i was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand
boom guess what next year oh by the way
this money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy account
holy means
okay i'm gonna put a hole in your face
if you touch my money
nobody could get this money this is a
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man i could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29 what am i
doing right here okay one two three four
boom i got 25 000 sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and i'm five
years into the plan
but when i was ready to start investing
money i started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32. i'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
charters showing off going on vacations
all i'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens i have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know i had 25 000 to add to my 25 000
next year i'm making more money i got 25
000 you see what i'm doing i'm stacking
dough
and looking
for 20
i know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to one million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay your job is to find a vehicle
that can pay you 20 percent a year might
be a business might be the business
you're in it might be to buy advertising
for the business or brand you're in for
me it was this i'm gonna buy real estate
that over long periods of time
i will earn cash flow okay that's how
the real estate works
i put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
[Music]
you said yeah but grant you said what'd
you say grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah i
know what i said
this ain't eddie okay now how much do i
have i could reinvest that money back in
the deal the next year i have 27
[Music]
500.
i earned 10 on that
that's 27.50 or something like that
i reinvest that now i got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as i own it over
20 years
2038 will dispose of this thing the rent
is going up as i'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 a year
by the time i sell i want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
a year
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that
for long periods of time the trick is
long periods of time
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one one-on-one i did
recently with grant check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created investing
elon musk is completely
invested he has no cash and no houses